spécial présente quatre nouveaux
smartphones on MWC on va voir quatre
références intéressantes le 406 le 408
le 40 se et le 40 r 40 r lui il sera 5G
on va commencer sur des smartphones à un
petit peu moins de 100 euros pour aller
jusqu'à 200 voir 250 € à peu près en
fait rafraîchir la gamme des produits
qu'ils avaient l'année dernière il y a
pas de grand grand chamboulement des
caméras qui ont un peu plus de
mégapixels des écrans toujours grand une
config un peu plus Pékin un peu plus
musclé en tout cas c'est intéressant de
voir cette évolution de la gamme de
Tesla c'est vrai que tu essayes on les
voit pas trop trop au niveau des
smartphones ils ont présenté souvent des
prototypes qui sont super intéressant je
vous ai parlé également d'une expeper
qui va très bientôt arriver sur un
smartphone dans l'année probablement
allez savoir on est tombé sur lui dans
l'entrée de gamme est-ce que ça des
produits que vous avez testé vous êtes
beaucoup parlé des écrans TCL au travers
de la télévision ce sont des produits de
super qualité est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu regarder ce que vous êtes déjà
intéressé au fait d'avoir un smartphone
de TCL je suis très curieux de savoir
marqué moi ça bien évidemment on va dans
les commentaires